les auditions du voisinage ont permis de
préciser à cette heure le déroulement
des faits ainsi l'un des voisins
domicilié face à la scène du crime
expliqué que alors qu'il se trouvait
dans son jardin il entendait les cris
d'une dispute entre nommer une femme
puis deux détonations il voyait alors
une femme allongée sur le trottoir un
homme se trouvait au dessus du corps
avec un bidon à la main à rauzan dans un
premier temps la tête puis le corps un
fusil de chasse étaient posés au sol à
côté de l'homme le témoin se
précipitaient vers l'homme pour
s'interposer mais celui-ci muni d'un
briquet mettaient le feu au corps avant
qu'il ait le temps d'intervenir à cet
instant alors que le voisin se trouvait
à hauteur de l'homme
ce dernier sortait un pistolet de sa
poche et le braquer la victime hurlait
sur le trottoir calmement tout en
braquant le témoin l'homme prenait son
fusil et le plier il sortait deux
cartouches en remettait une ou deux dans
le fusil et l'auteur partait en petite
foulée vers le fond de la rue en
direction du domicile de la victime
il était interpellé par les services de
la bac dont je tiens à saluer le
professionnalisme et la rapidité dans la
dans leurs interventions et l'individu
est interpellé à 18h45 au niveau du 75
rue de la rue léon-blum à pessac